bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour votre programme culturel
au kiosque sur 50 ans divine et ses
environs tout de suite le sommaire de ce
mercredi 9 décembre
nous recevons en plateau pour célébrer
les 20 ans du groupe vocal imagine jean
chapelle président de l'association
ainsi que deux choristes nadia benyahia
et albert saisi kgs et ils nous
parleront de leur prochain concert
samedi 19 décembre à la ferme du manet
de montigny le bretonneux nous
rejoindront aussi en plateau dans
quelques instants le duo generation
formé de théophile salamon et augustin
et rayman pour évoquer le concert
spécial reggae samedi soir à la batterie
de guyancourt ils sont la première
partie de yanis audois la maison
deyrolle s'invite dans la galerie du
trianon palace versailles jusqu'au 7
janvier pour une exposition d'animaux
merveilleux naturalisé l'association de
deux maisons de luxe pour célébrer la
magie de noël avant de saluer nos
premiers invités
je vous propose tout de suite de revenir
sur le spectacle de norbert hier soit
anciens candidats de top chef à la salle
jacques-brel de montigny le bretonneux
images de camille lambert attendons à
rien ça parle mais ce sont là deux des
gens bien mystère dépendance
vous l'avez sans doute reconnu
norbert originaire des yvelines et
demi-finaliste de la troisième saison de
top chef était hier soir sur la scène de
la salle jacques-brel de montigny le
bretonneux pour son spectacle chaud
patate
l'occasion de partager sa passion sur
scène avec le public ça fait dix ans
qu'on bosse de la cuisine à la télé tout
le monde y ait deux mois donne son petit
avis ton monde y va de son petit
commentaire à l'intro et m'a pas trop
basses qu'on la voit qu'à la télé et je
me dis pour ferait pas au théâtre
pourquoi ne viendrait pas cette cuisine
vivante
au delà d'un restaurant de la télé on a
fait venir dans un spectacle et dans un
théâtre qui ont fait vivre les gens ont
fait vivre les gens de l'intérieur les
coulisses d'une cuisine pendant deux
heures norbert nous prépare un menu aidé
de ses deux commis hors du commun tous
deux champions du monde de breakdance
quelques spectateurs ont même eu la
chance de le rejoindre sur scène un show
égrainé d'anecdotes liées à son parcours
et de conseils culinaires on ironise la
cuisine on ironise la télé on parle de
choses sérieuses menées sous forme très
ironique pour faire passer des petits
messages subliminaux comme ça pour faire
prendre conscience aux gens sans être
dans la morale mais juste dans
l'interrogation est de parler de tout
départ et des clients qui lui prennent
la tête des faux noms des restaurants
qui seront même pas compte qu'ils ont
des demandes totalement incongru voilà
de parler des produits qu'on travaille
des gens qui se mêlent de notre métier
qui sont pas du métier c'est un
cuisinier qui monte sur scène qui
rendent la cuisine
norbert continue à faire le show tout au
long de sa tournée et vous aurez
peut-être même la chance de le croiser
dans l'un de ses deux restaurants en
région parisienne salut à présent nos
premiers invités en plateau avec moi
j'en chapelle président de l'association
groupe vocal imagine nadia benyahia alto
et solistes et albert saisi kgs et basse
du groupe vocal à tous les soirs à tous
les trois pardon bonsoir alors le groupe
vocal imagine implanté sur montigny fête
aujourd'hui ses 20 ans et pour célébrer
cet événement vous serez sur la scène de
la ferme du manet samedi
descendre à 20h30 pour un concert qui
aura pour fil rouge l'histoire du jazz
je vous propose tout de suite de les
découvrir lors de leurs deux derniers
concerts
c'est
c
tiens
à
jean chapelle je lui disais vous êtes
actuellement le président de
l'association un mois peut-être pour
présenter ce groupe vocal
alors nous sommes un groupe vocal qui
chante on du case donc jazz anglo saxons
jazz français jazz latino et et du
gospel aussi et nous sommes basés à
montigné comme vous l'avez dit nous
répétons une fois par semaine voilà nous
sommes trente choristes et quand on l'a
on se produit en concert plusieurs fois
par an soit des concerts qu'on produit
nous mêmes dans les montagnes et bien
sûr et puis dans les villes alentours
soit aussi pour des oeuvres caritatives
reviendra un petit peu plus tard alors
avec vous on ne parle pas de chorale
mais de groupe vocal expliquer pourquoi
oui oui alors le groupe n'est introduit
une notion de modernité ça nous sort un
peu de doute du cas enfin du terme un
peu c'est pas péjoratif mais les gens
qui certaines personnes ne se
retrouverait pas dans une chorale
si vous voulez venir nous
nous rejoindre parce qu'on est un groupe
à la fois sur scène et aussi dans la vie
donc à chaque fois on fait des des
rencontres entre nous des rencontres
festives et puis
mais la différence vous la voyez
vraiment au niveau de la synergie parce
que fois qu'il a été question également
que lorsque vous êtes sur scène
vous n'êtes pas immobile et vous ne
lisez pas de partition tout est fait là
on chante vraiment parker mémorisées
voilà donc ça c'est une exigence de tous
les instants d'autres répétitions tout
le monde est impliqué à 100% pour finir
à jouer pour fournir un spectacle de
qualité et qui va certainement réjouir
les spectateurs qui viendront nous voir
à notre concert il ya également une
expression corporelle une expression
scénique nadia oui tout à fait on fait
également des chorégraphies donc c'est
vrai que les chorales ont des
chorégraphies ac je dirais légère fins
et des mouvements simples sur place nous
c'est vrai qu'on se déplace beaucoup sur
scène on a des chorégraphies qui sont
très variés vous travaillez avec des
professionnels également tout à fait on
aime chorégraphe qui s'appelle fabienne
guyon qui elle-même voilà où nous en
sommes d'accord alors n'aviez-vous le
jean le disais tout à l'heure
donc c'est un groupe vocal de jazz quel
répertoire particulièrement c'est ce
qu'il disait c'est très vaste en fait on
faire du latino du jazz français du jazz
anglo saxons c'est vraiment naze
éclectique vous balayer tous les
répertoires de jazz alors non général on
a
on a un thème en fait sur l'année et
ensuite on va rechercher donc il ya des
propositions de chacun il ya un bureau
qui travaille énormément et qui du coup
par rapport aux propositions et aussi
entre eux font des choix de la chanson
fonction du thème en fait on a eu trois
3 thèmes qu'on peut citer on a eu une
année on a fait du nougaro 1 c'était un
répertoire essentiellement nous verrons
comme quoi on fait aussi du jazz pensait
on a eu l'imaginent fait son cinéma donc
basé sur des musiques de films toujours
jazz et des musiques de films et puis là
cette année
l'histoire du jazz alors vous en dirai
un petit peu plus
tout à l'heure il ya également d'autres
artistes sur le territoire qui
pratiquent des répertoires de jazz un
peu différent et qui pour le coup a lié
le lyrisme à leur jesse comme ton inc
aux jeunes un géant du jazz qui vient
présenter son premier album feeder ce
samedi soir à 21h sur la scène du prix
sema ils encourront l'écoutent
à
on
non
nadia c'est un style de jazz auquel vous
êtes sensible un peu les ricains dc oui
c'est très particulier je pense car
c'est vrai que moi j'ai fait beaucoup de
musique donc j'apprécie l'écoutent
par contre au niveau du chant c'est pas
quelque chose que j'aime pratiquer donc
tout à l'heure je le disais vous êtes
alto et solistes quelle est la
principale différence en fait lorsqu'on
chante au sein d'un groupe vocal ou
lorsqu'on peut être chanteur solo alors
quand on chante dans un groupe vocal
siri déjà on nous on a la particularité
d'être un gros nez une trentaine donc
c'est une chorale qui a une groupe vocal
est assez important mais pas trop non
plus donc du coup on est quand même très
cohésif on voit là c'est un petit groupe
mais ça permet quand même de faire
beaucoup de voix s'élèvent peut-être
voilà un au niveau de la polyphonie
c'est vraiment très agréable
moi j'adore j'adore être au milieu du
groupe parce qu on entend toutes les
voies les mélanges enfin la polyphonie
c'est vraiment quelque chose doit la
cote je pense que quand on fait partie
d'un groupe vocal bas c'est quelque
chose qu'on apprécie énormément album
vous répétez vraiment à chaque fois tous
ensemble il ya cette forme de synergie
vous lisiez on est à la fois un groupe
vocal mais aussi un groupe dans la vie
c'est important ah oui c'est très
important parce que ça se voit tout de
suite quand on se rencontre à
l'extérieur confettis fait un trône
d'ailleurs c'est des moments
extraordinaires pour faire du chant pour
chanter entre nous et puis quand on se
retrouve sur scène dans les répétitions
dans le travail
on est complémentaires mais on sent
vraiment que cette cohésion produit
produit un travail est de qualité un
travail fils efficace mais qu'on glisse
oui tout à fait il est vrai cohésion et
ça se ressent sur scène alors donc gens
que vous nous disiez tout à l'heure que
le thème de cette année c'est l'histoire
du jazz
alors oui 20 ans c'est quand même un
événement important et donc on s'était
dit bah on a du répertoire un petit peu
de toutes les périodes de chasse et puis
on a travaillé comme nadia le disais
tout à l'heure sur quel serait le thème
de nos 20 ans et puis bale
l'idée est venue l'histoire du jazz et
donc là on fait notre concert et se
retrace l'histoire du jazz des premiers
chants de dans les champs de coton les
esclaves noirs dans le sud des états
unis
et puis ensuite on va passer dans les
années 20 les années folles le swing le
rac times le blues bien sûr avec une
ambiance plutôt caf de jazz
et puis dernière période le jazz plutôt
moderne avec des reprises aussi de
gospel un kiki et lui il veut spel il a
été qu'ils arrêtent au long de
l'histoire des thèmes repris encore
encore récemment
voilà donc notre conseil il est
structuré en trois étapes avec 3 mise en
scène différente avec des décors des
lumières des costumes d'envoyer qu'on
est au bocal web révèle un vrai travail
c voilà voilà
et bien c'est avec plaisir que l'on
pourra venir en découvrir plus et avoir
le plaisir de vous écouter samedi 19
décembre à la ferme du manet de montigny
le bretonneux messieurs tattoo les trois
messieurs dames pardon merci beaucoup
merci d'être venu sur le plateau du
kiosque aujourd'hui
alors pour continuer à parler musique
sachez que le conservatoire de musique
de la ville de montigny organise une
semaine dédiée à la musique
contemporaine jusqu'au 12 décembre pour
l'occasion de concerts et de master
classes sont proposées toutes les infos
à retrouver sur le site de la ville de
montigny le bretonneux
sans transition je vous emmène dans la
très belle galerie de noël du trianon
palace versailles qui s'est associé
cette année à la maison deyrolle pour
célébrer la magie des fêtes de fin
d'année une exposition en accès libre
jusqu'au 7 janvier
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude un peu de rêve et de féerie
pour célébrer la magie de noël
c'est dans cet esprit qui a été décoré
la galerie du trianon palace versailles
par la maison deyrolle l'association de
deux maison plus que centenaire qui
nourrissent les mêmes valeurs
cette année en vous
un thème que plus féeriques donné
l'opportunité tant aux adultes qu'aux
enfants de redécouvrir un peu la nature
association avec des rôles nous est
venue de par notre enfance vous parlez
souvenir nous avions des des blagues
d'affiché de dessins des rôles ainsi des
livres qui produit transformé en cabinet
de curiosités la galerie accueille des
animaux merveilleux naturalisé par la
maison deyrolle papillons multicolores
en bleu ouah renard zèbres et ours
blancs des animaux tous décédés de mort
naturelle en zoo une façon de donner une
deuxième vie et de porter à la
connaissance du public des animaux qui
peut être un jour disparaîtront comme
les ours polaires deyrolle est une
société sciences naturelles si une
société qui porte la nature là où elle
est c'est à dire où elle doit tête c'est
à dire dans un souci de préservation
d'observation de compréhension et tout
l'esprit de cette exposition c'est de
montrer que dans la sublime beauté il ya
un temps une très très grande fragilité
cette fragilité de la nature il faut et
si justement de l'intégrer dans notre
conscience pour être des acteurs de
cette préservation
cette exposition éphémère est en accès
libre jusqu'au 7 janvier
l'occasion de découvrir un univers
chimérique dans un très bel endroit et
nous poursuivons cette émission avec le
duo generation qui vient de nous
rejoindre en plateau alors bon soir à
augustin et rayman et théophile chez la
montre vous serez sur la scène de la
batterie à guyancourt au samedi soir
pour un concert spécial reggae augustin
vous faites partie et donc de 7 avec
théophile de cette nouvelle génération
de reggae jamaïcain implora gars qui
vient rafraîchir
l'univers reggae à quoi est dû ce vent
nouveau dans l'univers du reggae c'est
une bonne question je pense que les gens
commencent à écouter beaucoup de nus de
musique qui sont un peu différentes de
ce qu'on peut nous proposer dans les
médias et je pense que le reggae c'est
une musique qui qu'il plaît de plus en
plus de gens et à votre avis théophile
pourquoi est-ce que le reggae si peu
médiatisé en france c'est vrai que par
rapport au rock par rapport au rap
on en parle moins alors il est peu
médiatisée parce que c'est je pense dans
les valeurs aussi du reggae d'être un
peu underground être spirituel de sites
une musique qui qui vient aussi du
ghetto à la base donc un moment
commercial exactement ça également vous
soulignez que les textes sont peut-être
un peu plus revendicatifs gentil c'est
l'essence du reggae je pense c'est une
musique qui protège sa triste au début
je pensais vraiment quelque chose qui
revendique vu que comme le dit théo à la
base ça vient d'eux voilà deux du ghetto
de jamaïque ses tresses et des textes
assez puissant à la base on est alors
bien je propose tout de suite qu on vous
découvre sur scène
alors trouvez votre duo existe depuis
cinq saisons racontez-nous votre
rencontre avec augustin alors notre
rencontre
s'il me rends compte que très rigolote
puisqu'on était en fait du rock'n'roll
tous les deux ans 4e 3e et puis on a eu
deux groupes qui étaient un peu
concurrents dans le même collège et
finalement donc tous à arrêter puis on
s'est revus voilà un jour la gare de
saint cloud et sur ses limites il faut
qu'on fasse de la musique ensemble on
avait alors on en arrive bien sûr la
musique ensemble
et comme on était tous les deux font
draguer bon on s'est dit pourquoi pas
monter un groupe de reggae c'est très
bien apparemment ça fonctionne bien
alors aux questions vous êtes encore
donc tous les deux étudiants c'est
vraiment rapport passion que vous avez
tous les deux à la musique vous étiez
musiciens même oui bah pour l'instant
c'est vrai qu'au début on a on a
commencé comme le commodité aux affaires
du rock c'était on était plus musicien
que j'enterre même à la base est
effectivement pour l'instant ça reste
encore une activité parallèle mais c'est
vrai qu'on a la chance que le projet se
développe bien et même très bien donc
c'est c'est très encourageant pour la
suite web
théophile et skier à une technique
vocale un peu particulière dans le
reggae ragga pour une technique vocale
particulière c'est un peu comme dans
mamma par exemple et des accélérations
qui sont peut-être plus technique que
masquer technique je pense que c'est
surtout l'apprentissage de la langue
jamaïcaine qui impacte loi donc un
créole anglais et qui extrêmement rythmé
extrêmement riche en rythmant en
musicalité donc c'est ça qui est qui et
qui est très intéressant à prendre en
tout cas et justement pourquoi est ce
que parce que donc c'est ça vous chante
est en fait en anglais jamaïcain
pourquoi est ce que vous avez fait ce
choix justement parce que c'est plus
rythmé que ça me parle plus ça nous
parle plus que
et que c'est que les musiques qui nous
ont influencés je pense c'est surtout
parce qu'on a écouté beaucoup de ce
genre de musique mais que ça nous
paraissait en fait à un choix naturel
d'utiliser cette langue et puis on a une
affinité particulière tous les deux pour
l'anglais je pense le second but parce
qu'on pourra dire quoi si ça me plairait
que des puristes
moi je pense que le reggae c'est un peu
multi multi couleurs multifacettes s'est
pas vraiment oui en soit si parce que le
reggae en jamaïque et que voilà c'est la
plus grande scène s'est développé là-bas
que si oui en un sens je pense qu'on
peut dire des choses alors d'autres
artistes géant le pratiquer un peu
différemment et préfère voir un ragga
reggae un peu plus traditionnel comme
yannis audois donc on vous ferez sa
première partie on y reviendra tout à
l'air qui chante en français depuis
vingt ans on l'écouté
ok ça qu'est ce que ça fait d'être la
première partie comme ça c'est un grand
honneur c'est sûr on a eu une très très
belle une très belle saison de concerts
là qui ont eu la chance de faire partie
de tout ça voilà on a eu la chance de
faire beaucoup de très belle première
partie notamment tiken jah fakoly aussi
qui est un poids lourd du reggae là
c'est aujourd'hui enfin vendredi ce sera
effectivement yaniss odua c'est vraiment
un honneur parce que c'est un grand
monsieur un grand musicien et grands
artistes qu'on a quand même beaucoup et
alors théophile je sais que vous
composez on fait aussi bien la musique
que vous créez vous mêmes vos textes et
ce sont des textes à un message quels
sont vos thèmes de prédilection alors
notre thème de prédilection
ben ça qu'on ne m'a pas vraiment après
mons appelé generation parce que donc on
fait partie de cette nouvelle génération
qui est une génération qui est assez
consciente qui est consciente des
preuves qu'il ya dans le monde qui est
qui est assez relativement éduquer donc
qu'il ya plein d'armes en fait pour
pouvoir vraiment s'approprier le monde
et donc nos thèmes préférés
j'ai peut-être parler pour moi ça va
être voilà l'espoir halle est si légère
voilà des messages d'encouragement pour
pour notre jeunesse en gros énormément
quoi vous serez donc sur la scène de la
batterie samedi soir en première partie
de gagner au doigt et je sais également
que vous travaillez sur votre premier
album qui sortira peut-être l'été
prochain en tout cas on l'attend merci à
votre dieu generation d'avoir été avec
nous en plateau ce soir et on continue
avec une autre résidence artistique
celle de la compagnie de la cordonnerie
au théâtre de saint quentin en yvelines
pour préparer et ajuster les derniers
spectacles les derniers détails de son
ciné spectacles blanche neige ou la
chute du mur de berlin images de jérémy
quesada blanche-neige revisité
les artistes de la cordonnerie nous
propose une version moderne de ce
célèbre conte au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en lumbres et
quand l événement historique de la chute
du mur de berlin avec poésie et humour
il nous parle des murs qui s'érigent
entre les êtres on avait très envie de
se dire tiens aujourd'hui en 2015 de
commandes s'est encore les petites
filles aujourd'hui regarde blanche neige
dans leur lit blanche-neige et leur
expliquer autrement les cibles aux biens
mais non là la femme âgée qui avait fait
une quarantaine d'années qui est en
train de vieillir n'est pas forcément
jalouse de sa belle fille et ce qui nous
intéressait aussi et c'est théophile
comment un événement historique tels que
la chute du mur peut déterminer la vie
des gens aussi comment est-ce qu'on ait
influencé les uns les autres par des
choses importantes pour prendre les
décisions parce que tu as causé un
électrochoc
un spectacle original qui mêle plusieurs
arts celui du cinéma du théâtre de la
musique et du bruitage un film muet
d'abord réalisé en amont et la bande son
est réalisée en direct sur scène par les
deux metteurs en scène à la fois
comédien et bruiteur et par deux
musiciens un concept signature de la
compagnie de la cordonnerie
c'est un peu la confrontation entre un
quelque chose qui est définitif fini de
films immuable qui bouge pas et puis la
fragilité
et l'invention obligatoire de d'un live
avec quatre personnes qui doivent
refaire toute la bande son d'un film
l'idée c'est vraiment de créer aussi un
décalage entre l'objet film est l'objet
scénique et donc c'est très intéressant
de nous retrouver à la fois à l'écran et
sur le plateau presque une semaine de
représentations pour ce spectacle au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
si vous souhaitez vous initier à l'art
du bruitage un atelier proposé samedi au
théâtre par les artistes de la compagnie
et maintenant du ciné spectacle je vous
emmène dans les salles de vos cinémas
pour votre rubrique cinéphiles de la
semaine quels sont vos avis sur les
nouveautés au micro de jérémy quesada
c'est un super fut une aventure
c'est l'histoire réelle de moby dick on
apprend
parra comptines à 30 mais c'est un super
film il ya beaucoup d'humanité en scène
en fait c'est un beau grand film
d'aventuré à l'ancienne je dirais avec
de grands sentiments
des effets spéciaux pas trop marqué ce
qui est appréciable de nos jours parce
qu'on en prend plein les yeux d'habitude
et franchement c'est vraiment un film
peut-être pas tout public parce que pour
les enfants c'est un peu violent mais
vraiment une bonne surprise
j'aimais touchant et
une sorte de spiritualité qui
quadrillait un peu tout là toute
l'histoire
lellouche c'est vraiment quelqu'un dans
le cinéma x à part et je peux pas dire
et aucun de ces films qui m'a déplu
vraiment c'est vraiment super si adoré
de le fond de l'histoire
l'interprétation forcément voilà la
musique tout cette semaine c'est le beau
quand ginestet d'elancourt qui vous
donne son avis et son coup de coeur de
professionnels le cocker du ciné cette
semaine c'est le dernier film des frères
larrieu arnaud et jean-marie
personnellement grand fan depuis
longtemps qui s'appelle 21 nuits avec
paty donc avec une très belle
distribution isabelle carré on aurait pu
se lier et puis la magnifique somptueuse
extraordinaire karin viard qui tourne
beaucoup en ce moment donc c'est une
histoire encore une fois complètement
abracadabrante on va dire que nous ont
habitués les frères larrieu c'est
l'histoire d'une femme de 40 ans qui
revient dans un village des pyrénées
évidemment puisque les frères larrieu ne
cessent de mettre en scène les pyrénées
leur amour des pyrénées dans chacun de
leurs films pour enterrer sa mère qui
était une femme une avocate volage avec
laquelle et pc distant on va dire elle
va rencontrer tout un tas de personnages
truculents extraordinaire d'andré
dussollier à karin viard qui joue le
rôle de villageoises énamouré de tous
les hommes du coin on va aller de fête
de village en fête de village et puis
finalement le corps de la mère va
disparaître j'en dis pas plus
voilà donc c'est un film un peu
foutraque très original comme d'habitude
c'est du cinéma français avec un ton
très particulier donc après par exemple
pas nous faire l'amour ou leur dernier
film l'amour est un crime parfait
je vous encourage vraiment à venir
découvrir le dernier film des frères
larrieu vingtaine nuit avec paty
ce même petit coup derrière hamlet
bonbons et avant de se quitter je vous
propose tout de suite quelques dates
pour votre agenda culturel vendredi soir
20h30 rendez vous à la salle
jacques-brel de montigny le bretonneux
pour une soirée de l'humour avec laura
l'onea médecine là tout de suite un
extrait la prochaine fois tu en grand
producteur te propose de coucher avec
lui j'espère que tu auras l'intelligence
d'accepter
oui il était très énervé il a dit le
showbiz c'est comme les toboggans à la
piscine on avance plus vite quand on se
couche
même si parfois ça fait mal au cul le
fils de l'aspirateur bas ils comment ils
l'ont fait
ce soir on est en famille
on va pas se mentir à 21 ans j'ai donc
pris une décision je vous adore j'ai
fugué le jour vendredi et samedi 20h30
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
retrouver baisse à ringing pour vous
faire vibrer au rythme d'un standard
téléphonique que new york est une
comédie musicale made in broadway
samedi et dimanche à la merise de
trappes pour retrouver la famille
morallès pour leur spectacle in vino
veritas
une nouvelle création entre cirque et
théâtre avec équilibristes jongleurs
magie et poésie
enfin du kiosque pour ce soir émission à
voir et à revoir sur notre site internet
merci de nous avoir suivis je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée